okay now I'm gonna cover the slit
experiment and the slit experiment I
think is a yeah I think it was uh
Richard Fineman and he said you know
splitting experiment is what finds
quantum mechanics because that's the one
that drove them nuts they said harvest
mother nature do this and they couldn't
figure it out and they said look you
know sometimes light behaves a particle
something there's a way for some
experiments we have to use the wave and
for others we have to use the particle
and so they ended up within a political
agreement they said look oh you wait
theorists come over here all the
particle physicist come over here
let's kiss and make up and this is
called a wing particle or a wave packet
or whatever and so they kissed me may
not they never fought again and
everybody's happy to this day because
they don't do physics again like Max
Born says it's become more and more
abstract okay so what do we have here
double slit the physical interpretation
I'm gonna give you the physical
interpretation for the slit experiment
okay so what is this live experiment
well we have mr. francisco Grimaldi 1665
and he wrote in his fiscal Malthus is
the Luminess and he said you know when I
run light from two tiny slits I produce
these fringes on a wall it's just that's
so strange because you know I can't
understand how this works we come to
1801 Thomas young and specifically he
ran an experiment in which he reproduced
from all these results but more
importantly he reproduced an experiment
done by Newton had read of Grimaldi's
accomplishments and he went in there and
he took one of his hairs I think it was
one of his hair he did a heron
well this hair out he said let's see
what does it do with the hair because
Grimaldi had done with two slits ran
might reduce Lizzie from producing in
her friend interference fringes on the
wall and he says what if what if I put a
hair what would happen then so knitted
with hair and he produced fringes as
well and so Tom's young comes 200 years
later 100
yeah he says I want to try this let's
see what happens he did it with a hair
and he also did it with a wire and this
is his third experiment and he did it
with a human hair and he measured the
width of the hair he made all these
calculations yeah
effectively you know you can produce
this effect this so-called split
experiment with a hair somehow that got
buried in history until feel Goethe dug
it back up again because nobody done it
with a hair which is much easier to do
with the hair than it is to do with two
slits you got to get those slits not
only very funny
cut they have to be very thin but you
have to have them very close together
Thomas Young Knapp try to do he says I'm
gonna try to do the same experiment and
he said he also Purdue reproduce fringes
on the wall in order for you and I
understand that you know if you have a
single slit and you run light through it
it's like shining light through you know
maybe the keyhole
you know lunch and dinner just opens up
and it means whatever the wall whatever
is out there right it just kind of opens
up and that's what you see with a single
slit but you can't do that with like a
needle or a hair or a wire because they
the the light is blocked by the wires so
now you can't have that same situation
so it's a little different it's like is
the half if is the glass half full or
half empty you know that's kind of that
kind of situation is it the same thing
to run light through a slit than it is
to run in you know against the needle or
a wire or a hair and have light go
around it okay and that's what we're
looking at that comparison okay so I
decided to repeat mr. Young's experiment
and I did it with a hair I did it with a
needle so here you can see on the left
hand side you'll see the needle stuck to
a cork I sang a laser pointer at it you
can see the laser hitting the needle on
the right hand side and at the far end
of the wall you can see that there's a
light you see that there right when you
walk all the way up there
you see that's what you
we'll find you will find interference
fringes you see all this all these
fringes extending out from the center
flying and that's what we have to
explain how does Mother Nature produce
that effect okay and so how do they
explain it well here's another way that
we explain today they say well imagine
that light is made of particles okay
the particles go out and hit the side of
the window of the slit and they bounce
it in words and they interfere with the
other ball that's hitting the other
frame
you know they meet somewhere in the
screen and where they meet with the same
frequency with the same phase they have
a bright man and when they don't meet
you know when they're out of phase well
they have a dark man that's how it's
explained today but what if we replace
that double slit with a needle in other
words what if we take the to the top of
the piece on the top and a piece on the
bottom and just leave the center point
and you produce interference fringes
anyway
that ball would have nothing against
which to bounce that's the problem and
here it is let's remove them one and two
I remove now now what is it going to
bounce against see the problem the
problem is the light should go straight
forward it should never hit anything
there's no bouncy and so now we have a
problem because now we can't explain
what particles why is this important
because we had mr. Albert Einstein and
mr. Niels Bohr and they debated 1927 at
the 5th solving conference and they
debated for hours just what I showed a
minute they said oh yeah we can just run
the ball against the frame of the slit
and it bounces inwards very simple right
and it turns out that you can't do that
with the knee doping or what I call the
needle experiment you can cut the wire
experiment Newton's hair experiment
whatever you want to call it if you put
a hair there that's got nothing to
bounce against okay and there it is we
remove it and it's got nothing to bounce
against so now we have a problem because
we can't do with particle
and I'm gonna show in a second that we
can't do it also with waves okay so
let's see if we can do it now with waves
well again we have the same problem why
because a wave is a one directional you
know mechanism wave comes out of the
atom and should go straight just like a
particle so what do they do
why does the wave come in words well
this is the explanation that you get the
weight when it hits something you can it
turns into a party okay it collapses the
the wavefunction collapses into a
particle whatever that means to you
that's what it does okay but what's the
point the point is that they explain
this with waves with water waves they
said look if you wouldn't understand
this it's very easy just imagine water
going through a little slit and it'll
open up and in hips and if it hits water
coming from another slit well they're
interfere with each other because water
goes outwards you see here we have two
slits so then once look okay if you draw
two stones in them on you know these
ripples will expand and the ripples from
this guy will interfere with the ripples
of that guy that's what that image is
showing and what you see at the end are
the interference fringes you can see
light in this case red red black what is
the problem for the single slit water
goes out of the slid it just goes
outwards this is for wine okay and here
you see they've done it with a single
slit this is water this is actual
picture of a water tank that it's
vibrating so the water comes up and as
you can see it just goes upwards here
you see another one bottom one is
dynamic and they widened the slip and
you can see it just produces different
kinds of waves but they're always
outward going they never interfere with
each other so what is the problem the
problem is that they do it were waves
that's the problem is I see there is no
such physical object as a wave a wave is
a concept it's just something in motion
something that vibrates whatever wave is
and this is the typical pictorial
representation of a wave
the top one is a dynamic we have version
the bottom one is a static person
essentially a wave or the
electromagnetic wave is made out of two
fields one is the electric field the
other one is the magnetic field we get
that from mr. Maxwell they move forward
they only move in one direction this is
one of the problems and okay this is
what they say light is and this does not
actually behave very much like water
because what it does not really behave
exactly like what they're seeing light
does or a transverse wave it's okay
so keep that in mind okay so here we're
saying that what they've been looking at
all these years is a rope rope that
interconnects any two atoms in the
universe and you can see they're very
similar is the thing wave that they they
always give you as a pictorial
representation is nothing more than a
cross-section of a rope that's
essentially what a wave is there are
differences the electromagnetic rope is
structurally wavy but as the
electromagnetic wave is a dynamically
generated wavy thing a rope is pot so
it's stretched straight it's like if you
have a highway it's straight
cars can only go straight along that
highway because the highway is straight
and the question is why would the wave
they like to magnetic wave be straight
you know why doesn't it just wiggle and
go around and it doesn't is supposed to
go straight because if you shine the
light on a mirror or whatever you see
that it's completely straight you can
verify that for yourself it does travel
in a straight line and you're saying
well if it's a wave it's something come
coming out of the atom what is it just
wiggle and go anywhere it wants why does
it go exactly straight the torsion holes
can only travel reptil linearly along
you know rope so I'm you can show this
in your home with your grandmother it
slows line just move one of the
clothespins and you'll see how the whole
rope if it's pulled tight you know the
whole signal the torsion signal will go
straight you can't go any other way
because it's a torsion of the rope okay
and here you have again the problem with
the way that's one way whereas the rope
is side directional you know
you move a rope around we'll be both
ends are being affected is it's tight at
the other end here if the
electromagnetic wave is generated by an
atom it can only go in one direction
just like a party it's just that you're
replacing the particle with a way that's
why they have made it into a wave packet
because it was kind of Handy comfortable
and so on
okay and what is the problem well one of
the problems is this C equals frequency
times wavelength equation okay and you
don't have to be a you know rocket
scientist to understand this all we're
saying here is that if you increase the
frequency and you increase the
wavelength both simultaneously you
should be able to travel faster in mind
what physically prevents us from doing
that why can't we travel faster than
light if suppose that you're going to
increase the fleet mathematically right
you can increase the frequency into
wavelength so you make the wavelength
longer you make more you know per unit
time now you have festered right very
simple wander the rope model well you
can't do that see here's the rope model
you have a any length of rope here I
have a piece of the road here no more I
targeted and the more links I have
anything gets smaller so here we have
frequency times wavelength you uncork it
very simple you have fewer links and
each link is longer and then it gives
you an idea of why the speed of light is
a constant because it's mediated by rope
or at least it's a good I'm not here to
twist your arm just saying you know if
you think about it a rope is a good
model for what we're seeing for that
equation that equation is the equation
world you cannot increase both frequency
and wavelength because you cannot
increase on a given length of rope the
frequency the how many links you have
and how long they are you cannot do that
one is at the expense of the other and
that's what the equation shows okay so
this is what proposing in exchange for
what mathematical physics proposed in
mathematical physics says that all
particles are discrete nothing to do
with each other
they're separated by space they're not
connected and the rope model that I'm
proposing says that all atoms are
interconnect that's the bottom line
okay that's the fundamental difference
between what we have today and what we
have in the Rope model so how do we
explain a slit experiment we're saying
that before we turn the light on the
ropes are already connected from atom
down all atoms in this room are connect
once we turn the light on all we're
doing is increasing the frequency which
means that right here here we study
there is no light right this at this
point it's just dark now we're going to
turn the light on and now we do produce
a higher frequency now those same ropes
are torquing at a faster rate the atoms
are pumping at a faster rate and
torquing the rope that fast early so
suddenly you have this light what does
it turn the light on me it means that
you're gonna give the ad mustiness that
forces it to pump faster if it pumps
faster it's gonna torque the rope at a
faster frequent faster rate and what
that translates into is shorter links
and morning's higher frequency lower
okay and you know you see all these
atoms connected to the screen and each
one is affected okay so you're gonna see
all these roasts pointing to different
atoms on the screen and each one is
torquing out as fast as the pace then
you say well why doesn't the whole
screen light up why are there fringes
why are there separations so let's get
into that this is the explanation the
official explanation
they say when electromagnetic waves are
in phase you have constructive
interference both waves are in phase
when they're out of phase they cancel
each other out from a mathematical point
of view you see that at the bottom when
there are out of phase they can cancel
each other out
but that's only a mathematical
expression it doesn't give you a cold
why you know what's the cause first of
all there's no such thing as away but
even conceding why would they cancel
each other up for the rope you can see
that first what
we're gonna say look what the rope we
can do the same thing if they're in
phase you have constructive interference
and when they're out of phase you have
destructive interference okay now what
is the physical cause of this under the
roadblock you have the light coming from
around the needle you have only two
ropes here just to show the meccans
maybe I can show this with my hands you
know you have this situation where
you're moving like this so you have a
shift in the in the phase of each rope
with respect to each other and if you
just don't remember what I showed you
earlier where you had fringes you know
where I verified fringes with a needle
you'll see that it doesn't go completely
to dark there's always a reddish color
that fades out but then it comes back in
again it doesn't completely die out
there's always some amount of red it's
not as dark as the background itself
like if you look at the ceiling above
where the laser was pointed it's dark
and this is not completely dark and
again what you're saying is this
situation you're seeing something like
this okay that's what I'm showing there
okay and here you see from the person's
eye the ropes are coming from two sides
of the needle right there it's gonna be
from one side of the needle the other
one is from the other side of the needle
okay so they come to an atom here and
right now this first one here this is
the case where lights are turned off
nothing is on you haven't yet turn the
laser pointer on these are the ropes
they are connected simply from the
needle to an atom on the screen that's
the screen out of there and this is
anatomy in your eye okay now I put it on
this side because there was another way
otherwise it would have been quite
confusing to put it on that side but
you're really on this side looking at
the screen the screen is reflecting that
light through your eye okay so even
though I put the person over there the
person is really supposed to be on this
side okay I did that on purpose because
otherwise it would have been a little
too messy to show how the Rope comes
back you know along the same in the same
direction from where the light went okay
but just keep that in mind these are the
two
coming from each side of the needle here
you have Adam in on the screen it's
turned off that's why it's black and you
you don't see anything in that area
because there's been no light shining
okay that's what I'm trying to show
their second picture here now we're
going to turn the light on
okay we took the laser on light comes at
a greater frequency you can see the
difference in frequency here this has
more links and each link is shorter and
so now this thing is pumping to a wider
area in here you give it a stimulus oh
no this atom is going now suddenly it's
going you know wider expansion of the
atom and faster okay and that triggers
the signal to your eye this is the atom
in your eye receives that same signal
just relays that same thing why do we
have these dark bands this one has the
same number of links as this one but
they're out of phase like blue matches
red red matches blue they're out of
phase by half a link maybe I can show
you again you know if you have this
situation where you have here you have a
blue one and a red one can you all see
that okay and we're gonna pick that
against a red one against the blue one
okay and what I'm saying is even though
they come from the same light source
they're out of phase by one link or have
too late and they're off by half a link
and so what happens suddenly you get a
dark band in Europe you see why would
that be so why why does that happen and
we see that in the next image you're
seeing a blue strand of the rope and a
red strand of the rule they're coated
around each other and you're looking at
the rope head-on what you're seeing is
this right there okay something like
that and that's what you're standing and
you can see that the one on the left the
upper left they're both in phase but the
one on the right they're out of phase
one is up down the other one is
horizontal I'm gonna associate the two
on the left that are up and down with a
bright band and I'm going to associate
the one on the
right that's off by half a link the dark
back okay the guys on the bottom both of
them you can see they're just a
45-degree one of the one of the ropes is
45 degree with respect to the other and
those are those intermediate colors that
you will see you'll see a phasing out of
fading out of the color red because you
know you typically use a red color okay
and so now we get to this and here we
have a dynamic version this is what you
would see if you're the atom and you
have to a rope coming towards you right
and this is high frequency on the top
and you can see the atom is pumping
that's what you'll receive
why because both strand both ropes that
are meeting at your atom they're both in
phase so the element can expand through
both ropes without any problem no
impediment you know just expand because
they're both in phase giving you the
same signal simultaneously what happens
in the guy in the bottom well now you
have to superimpose you have one rope
that's like that the other one that's
sideways okay
they're superimpose remember they
arrived at the same point and so the
atoms trying to expand here when the
other one just gives it a different
signal to expand it in a different
direction so so the atom is trying to
expand like you did in the first guy you
know in the first case try and span
forward eating two links right and it
can't do that because one of the link is
sideways so it's trying to expand this
way when the other guys says no expand
that way and so that's the end is not
isn't blocked from expanding to its full
potential
that's what I'm saying is happening
that's my explanation for it maybe there
is a different interpretation that's
what I'm seeing that's happening if you
explain this with a ruler
so any quantum mechanics has no physical
interpretation for the slit experiment
first because they use concepts such as
speeding of the force etc energy you
need objects to explain something you
should be able to put something on the
board like I did here some physical
entities part of mechanics cannot
explain the slit experiment with waves
because there is no such thing as a wave
wave is what something does not what
something is
apparently at least provides a physical
interpretation for the slit experiment
why that happens okay and how is that
second part
[Applause]